„Mein lieber Herr Bandel, wie lang kennen wir uns jetzt schon?“
„30 Sekunden?“
„Genau. Und ich habe Sie gebeten hier vorbeizuschauen,
weil ich gesehen habe, dass mein Vater Ihnen nie so eine Berufsunfähigkeitsversicherung angedreht, ähh, angeboten hat.“
„Ich bin Schuhverkäufer und das ist ja nicht direkt eine Hochrisikobranche.“
„So schnell können Sie gar nicht schauen und es erwischt Sie in Ihrem Schuhladen.“
„Vielleicht wäre es wirklich besser mit so einer Berufsunfähigkeit...“
„... und wie das besser wäre. Safety first!
Schauen Sie her, ich habe da schon was vorbereitet. Sie müssen eigentlich nur noch da unterschreiben.
Auf Ihre Future, High Five!“
„Ich überlege mir das noch mal mit der Berufsunfähigkeit.
Ich glaube, das ist nichts für mich, aber Ihnen würde ich es empfehlen.“